[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wade innocence is taking 8 lectures that
he did for the Massey Lectures in Canada
this year last year and they were if you
want the long version the good version
of what he does tonight it's all in a
book called interesting enough the
wayfinders why ancient wisdom modern
matters in the modern world that will be
outside and Wade will be outside signing
those books after the time field
scientists lead the most exciting lives
there are I think I particularly find a
biologist but I noticed this series is
fond of anthropologists who come back
with a filled with stories to tell about
what being human really means we've had
Daniel Everett who's worked in Latin
America did amazing things about
language steven lansing working in bali
jared diamond working mainly in Papua
New Guinea first on birds then on people
the way davis has probably been to all
those places and ingested whatever they
have to offer not only lived to tell the
tale but has a hell of a tale to tell
wait
well thanks Stuart and thanks to so many
of you for coming out tonight and I feel
like I must know all of San Francisco I
have so many friends here and I'm
especially delighted to be here with my
youngest daughter who's just started
college in the Bay Area Raina who's in
the front row here so it's going to be a
great delight to come out and be with
you and with all of you in the future I
am gonna try to compress what we're
actually 5 lecturers delivered in this
remarkable Canadian institution whereby
you're given the platform to deliver a
lecture in each of one of five cities
and they're broadcast live on national
radio and Canada and edited into a book
it's a really wonderful tradition Martin
Luther King gave them just before he was
assassinated Claude lévi-strauss Carlos
Fuentes Margaret Atwood and it's a real
extraordinary kind of symbol of Canada's
attempt to give ideas a place in the in
the public sphere I guess I'll be
telling a lot of long stories tonight a
lot of stories of culture a lot of
stories of the spirit of being and I
often begin these talks with sort of a
reflection on the delights of travel and
what it really means for us and how it
really for me at least as a young
anthropologist and somebody asked me
earlier tonight how I became an
anthropologist and it was kind of a
serendipitous moment I grew up in Canada
at a time when the French and English
didn't speak to each other and I grew up
in an English suburb a community a
commuting suburb of Montreal it was sort
of plunked like a carbuncle on the back
of the flank of an old french-canadian
village it went back to the 17th century
and there literally was a road that
divided the two communities and my
mother used to always send me to this
corner grocery store owned by a
wonderful francophone couple to buy
cigarettes or to get milk or whatever
she needed and I remember sitting on the
edge of that road that divided these two
worlds knowing full well at the age of
five that across that Street was a
different language a different religion
a different way of being and I was
absolutely
enchanted not only the idea of the other
but by this strange and subtle
prohibition coming from my world about
crossing that road and fortunately I had
an absolutely wild older sister who
shattered that boundary by falling in
love with a francophone boy and the wake
of her elopement
I slipped through and became enchanted
with that other world and I think that's
really where this long journey of
culture began and one of the intense
pleasures as many of you know of travel
is indeed the opportunity to live in
these different worlds to realize that
our world is only one of many and a
chance to live amongst people who have
not forgotten the old ways who still
feel their past in the wind and touch it
in stones polished by rain tasted in the
bitter leaves of plants and just to know
in our hectic lives that in the Amazon
Jaguar shamans still journey beyond the
Milky Way or that in the High Arctic the
myths of the Inuit elders still resonate
with meaning or that in the Himalaya the
Buddhists still pursue the breath of the
Dharma is really to remember the central
lesson of anthropology and that is the
idea that the world into which we're
born does not exist in some absolute
sense but it's just a model of reality
and the other people's aren't failed
attempts at being us by definition their
unique answers to a fundamental question
what does it mean to be human and alive
and this in a sense really is a lesson
of anthropology and whether it's a
voodoo acolytes in Haiti the yak herders
on the slopes of Shulman Alma the Eagle
hunters of Central Asia or the
thunderhoof shaman of Mongolia all of
these peoples teach those of their other
ways of being other ways of thinking
other ways of orienting yourself in
social and spiritual and ecological
space and that's an idea that of course
can only fill us with hope now together
and some years ago when I became an
explorer in residence of the National
Geographic with this sort of mandate to
celebrate culture I coined this term
no spear trying to sort of forge an
organizing principle to describe this
extraordinary web of cultural life that
enveloped the planet and that was just
as important to the well-being of the
planet as indeed was the biological web
of life that we know as a biosphere and
at that time I defined the ethnosphere
as being the sum total of all thoughts
and dreams ideas and myths intuitions
and inspirations brought into being by
the human imagination since the dawn of
consciousness I I saw the ethnosphere
really as humanity's great legacy the
symbol of all that we achieved and the
promise of all that we could achieve as
a wildly creative and imaginative
species and at that time even as we
became more acutely aware of the
consequences of loss of biological life
with a loss of habitat and the loss of
plant and animal species through
extinction we are somewhat unaware in a
sense of a parallel process of loss I
remember when His Holiness the 14th
Dalai Lama first spoke in the West at
Harvard in the fall of 1979 and that
same night across the street kitty
corner to the science Hall Leo Wilson
was introducing Norman Myers who had
just written a book called the sinking
arc which was one of the first books to
draw attention to the emerging
biodiversity crisis and in apologizing
to the sparse audience because of course
all the kids were across the street to
hear his holiness Leo Wilson literally
said that if even Harvard students can
understand the importance of these
issues of biological diversity and they
would rather be across the street
listening to and I quote that religious
kook then we know how far we've got to
go now EO Wilson as decent and kind a
man and as brilliant a biologist who's
ever walked the earth would be the first
today to regret those remarks but it
shows you how far apart these worlds
were but thirty years ago in the
emerging days of conservation biology
the biologists were insensitive to the
plight of culture and the anthropologist
tended to view the the the biologists as
being miss misanthropic and indeed
insensitive in their callous regard in
fact elitist in their cows for guard for
the plight of culturable of course those
things have come together and I've tried
to use this term ethnosphere over the
over the years as that organizing
principle because when I first began to
do this research and I connected to the
linguistic community I was absolutely
astonished despite all my training in
anthropology I was really not aware of
the intensity of the crisis of language
loss and this of course is a canary in
the coal mine no biologist would suggest
that 50 percent of all plants and
animals are more than because it really
is not true and yet that the most
apocalyptic scenario in the realm of
biological diversity scarcely approaches
what we know to be the most optimistic
scenario in the realm of cultural
diversity and the great indicator of
this of course is language loss nobody
really knows how many languages there
are some people say the difference
between a dialect and a language is that
a language has an army but we basically
feel that there roughly 6,500 to 7,000
languages in the world of those half
aren't being taught to children which
means effectively they're moorland on
the brink of extinction now a language
is not just a body of vocabulary or a
set of grammatical rules a language by
definition is a flash of the human
spirit it's a vehicle through which the
soul of each particular culture comes in
the material realm every language I once
wrote is an old-growth forest of the
mind a watershed of thought an ecosystem
of social spiritual political
possibilities and to live through a time
when virtually half of the languages are
being lost is be is to live through a
time in which half of humanity's legacy
being sacrificed and of course there are
always those who say wait a minute
wouldn't the world be a better place if
we all spoke one tongue wouldn't
communication be facilitated wouldn't it
be easier to get along and my answer to
that is always to say what a great idea
but let's make that universal language
and nook to tuck let's make a Quechua
let's make it Haida let's make it
Tibetan and suddenly you begin to feel
as a native speaker of English what it
would be like to be enveloped in silence
to have no ability to pass on the wisdom
of your ancestry or to anticipate the
promise of your descendants but of
course that is the plight of someone
somewhere on earth every fortnight
because on average every two weeks some
elder slips away and carries with him or
her into the grave the last syllables of
an ancient tongue but what really is at
stake what do I mean when cultures are
lost we lose a part of ourselves well it
may seem odd in a lecture that
celebrates the the wonder of culture to
tip my hat to genetics but this is
really where the story begins
population biologists have at last
proven it to be true something that
falafel oscars have always dreamed to be
true and that is that we are all quite
literally brothers and sisters and I
don't mean that in the spirit of hippie
ethnography I mean quite literally we're
all cut from the same genetic cloth
studies of the human genome and studies
of the y-chromosome descendant through
the male lineage and mitochondrial DNA
through the female lineage have left
absolutely no doubt that the human
genetic endowment is a single continuum
it has suggested that race is an
absolute and utter fiction in fact we
can not only identify the place where
the Garden of Eden was we can also
identify the place in Africa where our
ancestors walked out of that continent
indeed all of humanity is descended from
a relatively small number of individuals
who roughly 55,000 years ago slipped
away from the ancient continent and in a
epic Hejira
of 2,500 generations
carried our species to every capital
corner of the planet but if you accept
that we're all cut from the same genetic
cloth there's an obvious corollary if we
are all cut from the same genetic cloth
we all share
by definition the same intellectual
potential there's the same raw mental
acuity the same capacity for thought for
belief for dreams and therefore how we
choose to use that Universal capacity is
simply a matter of choice we have a
conceit in the West that what we've been
developing technological wizardry
somehow the other peoples of the world
had been intellectually idle nothing
could be further from the truth we may
put a priority on technological
innovation but other people's such as
the aboriginal societies of Australia
plate pay attention more intensely to
unraveling the complex threads of memory
inherent in a myth but this revelation
finally puts the lie to the old 19th
century canard that there is a progress
in human affairs that goes from the
savage to the Barbarian to the civilized
of the Strand in London it shows without
any doubt that culture is only a
manifestation of options that there is
no ladder to success that conveniently
places ourselves at the top there's no
pyramid of success that places
industrialized Victorian society at the
apex of the pyramid that slopes down to
the so called primitives of the world
there really only are a series of
options and so the other peoples of the
world are not failed attempts at being
us their unique answers to this
fundamental question what does it mean
to be human and alive and when people
are asked that question they respond
with 7,000 different voices and those
voices collectively become our human
repertoire for dealing with the
challenges that will confront us in the
ensuing millennia I think ultimately
that's the great lesson of anthropology
and you know I was very fortunate I'm
sure many of you know the writings of
Matthieu Ricard who is the
translator for his holiness in in France
has written a number of wonderful books
including a book on happiness that made
the number one bestseller list he was
number one book in France I didn't even
know the French actually believed in the
concept of happiness he didn't either
but he somehow pulled it off but I
travelled with Mathieu in in Nepal to
make a film that we called the science
of the mind why did we use that term
science to describe Tibetan Buddhism
well what is science but the empirical
pursuit of the truth what is Buddhism
but 2500 years of direct observation as
to the nature of mind
Matthieu who himself was originally a
molecular biologist studying in the lab
of a Nobel laureate at the Pasteur
Institute outside of Paris said to me
one day that so much of Western science
is a major response to minor needs we
spend all of our lifetimes trying to
live to be a hundred without losing our
teeth we in Tibet he said spend all of
our lifetimes trying to understand the
nature of existence
he said that your billboards in the West
celebrate naked teenagers in underwear
our billboards are many walls of prayers
for the well-being of all sentient
creatures but what do I mean by
different ways of thinking making for
quite different possibilities of both
the human spirit but of the human
adaptation well let's slip for a moment
into the greatest culture sphere ever
brought in the bean by human beings that
of Polynesia tens of thousands of
islands flung like jewels upon the
southern sea a diaspora that we now know
began ten centuries before Christ off
the coast of New Guinea an ancient
civilization that we call Lapita within
ten centuries they had moved east as far
as Fiji and beyond to Tonga and Samoa
there for reasons we do not understand
it stopped for a thousand years the
ceramic tradition was lost but not
notions of the decoration of the human
body the nature of the ancestors that
divine origins of the wind and then
sometime around 200 years before the
birth of the Christian era what we now
know to be the modern Pauline
Asians began this extraordinary journey
sailing East from Samoa and Tonga
ultimately to Cook Islands Tahiti 4000
kilometers to the márquez's eventually
north to Hawaii
and then South East to Rapa Nui or
Easter Island and eventually around the
time of the First Crusade reaching back
to what we now call New Zealand and I
recently was able to sail with the
Polynesian voyaging society on a vessel
named the Hokulea after Arcturus the
sacred star of Hawaii this is a
recreated catamaran based on the
drawings made by Captain Cook's artist
and naturalist Joseph Banks and the
Hokulea has sailed throughout the South
Pacific recreating the journeys of the
ancestors and these are sailors who even
today can name 250 stars in the night
sky
these are sailors who can sense the
presence of distant atolls of islands
beyond the visible horizon simply by
watching and studying the reverberation
of waves across the hull of the vessel
knowing full well that every island
group in the Pacific has its own unique
refractive pattern that can be read with
the same perspicacity with which a
forensic scientists would read a
fingerprint
these are sailors who in the darkness of
the hull of the vessel can distinguish
as many as five different sea swells
moving through the canoe at any one
point in time distinguishing currents
that are caused by lower wave patterns
that are caused by local weather system
from the deep currents of pulsate
thousands of kilometers across the
Pacific and that could be followed with
the same ease with which a terrestrial
Explorer would follow a river to the sea
and the most amazing thing about this
tradition is that the Polynesians did
not have the written word and the entire
system of navigation was based on dead
reckoning dead reckoning simply
so you only know where you are by
remembering where you've come from and
it was the the impossibility of a long
voyage by means of dead reckoning that
kept European transports hugging the
shorelines of continents until the
British solved the problem of longitude
with the invention of the chronometer
but centuries before that the wayfinders
of the Polynesian civilization swept
across the greatest ocean on earth now
dead reckoning means that you have to
literally remember every change of
course every change of wind every
impression from the natural world over
the course of a long voyage the Hokulea
once sailed from Hawaii to Rapa Nui
now that's sailing 6,000 miles crossing
the doldrums tacking into the wind for
1,500 miles which effectively quadruples
the length of the journey all to reach
an island that was 25 kilometers across
less than a degree on a compass were a
compass in fact to have been on board
but of course there was no compass and
that journey was completed within our
lifetimes simply by the navigators of
the polynesian voyaging society reaching
back through the whispered threads of
memory into the tradition of the
navigators and bringing back this way of
travel to life and so indeed if you took
all of the genius that allowed us to put
a man on the moon and applied it to an
understanding of the ocean what you
would get is Polynesia now if we move
from the ocean to the forest and we
enter the greatest forest on earth we
come into the heart of the Amazon and
the Amazon invokes cliche even as it
defies hyperbole after all it's the
greatest expanse of forest on earth
larger than the continental United
States or more poetically put larger
than the face of the full moon and
virtually everything we understood about
the Amazon when I went to graduate
school
has been turned on its head it's really
fascinating you know Joseph Conrad
described the the the rainforest as the
jungle he said it's less a force and a
primeval mob of remnant of an ancient
era when vegetation rioted and consumed
the the world and this was the image of
the rainforest as Green Hell a kind of
an evil place by the time I came along
the the jungle had had become a term
that had gone long out of fashion and
the rain force itself had become an Eden
a kind of a delicate Eden often called a
counterfeit paradise that could clearly
endure our ways so long well this idea
of the rain forest is a delicate place
was informed in part by a basic
understanding of the nature of tropical
rainforest ecosystems and the fact that
the biological wealth is not within the
soil but within the living vegetation
itself and so the ideas you've all heard
is that if you remove that canopy you
set in motion a chain reaction of
destruction of cataclysmic significance
well this concept while useful as a
fundamental way of thinking about these
ecosystems when applied to a rain forest
the size of the continental United
States
was as much slogan as science and 50
years of field research has given us a
very different notion of what the amazon
in fact is now this of course is a place
of remarkable cultures people like the
Baader sana a people of the Anaconda who
believed that mythologically they came
up the Milk River from the east and the
belly of the sacred serpent only to be
regurgitated on the various affluence of
the Northwest Amazon a people who are so
entwined with that forest in their
adaptations that cognitively they do not
distinguish the color green from the
color blue because the canopy of the
heavens is equated to the canopy of the
rainforest I I'm going to tell you a
little bit of a complicated but
revelatory story I first went to live
with the but asana in 1974 and I felt
first of all they were about as far away
as you get from anywhere
the Northwest Amazon the Northwest
Amazon of Columbia is the size of France
and at the time I felt this was a
disappearing world and that was an old
canard of anthropologists at the time
and there was something going on here
that was extraordinary the unique and
special but anthropologists hadn't quite
figured out what it was our views of the
Amazon were much more commonly
influenced by what we had experienced
with other cultures people like the
Huaorani
who were a remarkable society living in
the eastern flanks of the Andes in in
Ecuador a people first peacefully
contacted in 1958 fully five years after
I was born
the Huaorani were a remarkable people in
part because in their isolation they had
created a kind of a intense intra tribal
warfare such that 54% of the mortality
was due to them spearing each other but
they did have a remarkable knowledge of
the forest their hunters could smell
animal urine at 40 paces and tell you
what form of life had left that behind
and these kinds of gifts enchanted
anthropologists and ethnographers ood
plants like this one
the flying death the kirari dart Venom's
that of course yielded d to Boca roaring
the muscle relaxant that revolutionized
medicine in the 1940s and we became
enchanted by the allure of the shaman
isolated individuals who took these
extraordinary metaphysical journeys into
the realm of the divine in order to work
their deeds of medical and mystical
rescue individuals who would use these
curious plants like a B'nai the semen of
the Sun the blood-red resin of several
species in the genus viola containing
powerful psychotropic agents
dimethyltryptamine five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine as Dennis as Terence
Mckenna the late Terence Mckenna
so famously said to have the stuff blown
up your nose was like being shot out of
a rifle barrel lined with baroque
paintings and landing on a sea of
electricity they created not the
distortion of reality it created the
there's illusion of reality in fact I
used to argue with my professor at
Harvard the legendary plant Explorer
Richard Evans salties the man who
sparked the psychedelic era with his
discovery of the magic mushrooms in
Mexico in 1938 that you really couldn't
classify these tryptamines as Lucena
genic because by the time you're under
the influence there was no one home
anymore to experience the hallucinations
but we became enchanted with this not
simply because of the dazzling
pharmacological effects of these plants
but what they told us about a different
way of knowing and the exemplar of that
of course is a plant that's become very
popular in the West ayahuasca the vision
vine the vine of the soul which
critically is not a plant but a
preparation now those tryptamines are
taken through the nose because they're
orally inactive because they're
denatured by an enzyme found naturally
in the human stomach mono amine oxidase
they can only be taken orally if taken
in conjunction with some other drug that
denatures the Mao and the human gut so
ayahuasca is actually a combination of
the leaves in this case of a nondescript
shrub in the coffee family chock-full of
tryptamines
and the bark of a nondescript woody
Liana filled with these curious beta
carbons harmine and harmaline which
turned out to be mao inhibitors of the
precise sort necessary to potentiate the
tryptamines and the reason is so
intrigued anthropologists and
ethnographers
how in a floor of 80,000 species of
vascular plants did the indigenous
people learn to combine these two
morphologically distinct denizens of the
rainforest in this powerful synergistic
way a kind of biochemical version of the
whole being greater than the sum of the
parts and the only answer we had
scientifically was trial and error which
was quickly exposed as being a
meaningless euphemism the Indians would
say the plants teach us Salty's famously
amongst the ciona and the Sequoia and
the Kofun in the 1940s identified 17
varieties of the ayahuasca Liana all of
which were referral to his Harvard
trained taxonomic I is the same
and yet the people recognized them
consistently in the forest and when he
asked them the nature of their
systematics they looked at him as if he
were a fool or a naive and they
explained that of course anyone who
studied plants would know that you took
each one of the 17 on the night of a
full moon and each one sang to you in a
different key well that's not going to
get you a PhD at Berkeley and plant
systematics but it's a lot more
interesting than counting flower parts
but it tells you something about a
different way of being now this is
really what I want to try to get around
to these what we call marginal societies
was a was a lens through which if I if I
mentioned that we had this idea of the
Amazon being this this delicate fragile
place that persisted in the literature
in part because it served a legitimate
environmental agenda and our concerns
with deforestation with the expansion of
the Brazilian frontier in particular
from the south but it also fit Western
preconceptions of what it meant to live
in the Amazon by the time Europeans had
modern contact with the Amazon of course
the main trunk had been deep populated
by disease at the time of contact and
the only extent societies were the
societies that we came to know as a
marginal societies not in a pejorative
term but these were simply the societies
that literally lived at the margins of
the Amazon basin unreachable because of
cataracts from below unreachable from
the west because the Andes weren't
traversed by roads until after World War
two and so when anthropologists flooded
into the Amazon in the 1960s these were
the real Indians that we were drawn to
see now typically these societies were
endogenous they married amongst
themselves often an open open conflict
with their neighbors they were
relatively simple in their technologies
simple in their social structures and
these were became the image we had of
the Amazon Indian but if we look back in
the journals of our Eliana Gasper de kat
Avadh who wrote in 1541
the first Europeans to go down the
Amazon it said that when they reached
the confluence of the Napo and the
Ucayali as the rivers are known in Peru
or Ileana went temporarily insane
because he couldn't understand how a
river on God's earth could be so big and
so that idea together with the fact that
they encountered the Amazon women and
the Amazon women immediately caused the
The Chronicle that Gaspar de Carvajal
to be denigrated and ridiculed not
because of what he said about the Amazon
but because he were repeated this canard
about Amazon women that every Explorer
had come home with because they had
learned it in the journals of Herodotus
and so Cortes found the black queen
calathea
which is why you call yourself
Californians you know Columbus found
warrior queens in the Antilles and so
the journals of Eliana's expedition were
kind of dismissed from history and they
weren't even published will 1895 but if
you look at those journals the minute
they reached the Napo they encountered
civilizations the entire river banks of
the Amazon were populated by thousands
of people we now know that the Amazon
was not an empty place but the homeland
of tens of millions of people we now
believe that slash-and-burn agriculture
is not this delicate way to live in the
forest but probably is a technology that
developed in the wake of contact in the
with the arrival of steel tools we now
know that 20% of the Amazon is made up
of black soils human-created soils the
people didn't slash and burn and move on
they had every incentive to stay put and
they did so there were these great
civilizations in the Amazon that
archaeology is only beginning to unveil
just last week you probably saw the
reports of the discoveries in Bolivia of
clearly huge concentrations of
populations the question is what came of
those vision
and is there a place in the Northwest
Amazon where such visions are still
alive and there is in the homeland of
the people of the Anaconda isolated
people who live very differently from
those marginal societies these are
people's like the bar asana the two
connell the mucuna but taiwan those
living in these incredibly complex
societies and these isolated black water
rivers incredibly complex ritual
activities knowledge-based traditions in
which the the Sivan is honoured beyond
the warrior living in great monumental
structures that in their in their
symbolic elaboration are as significant
as anything the Inka ever built rituals
institutions that facilitate peace not
war
not the least of which is a curious
marriage rule that in order to marry you
must marry someone who speaks a
different language and so in any one
longhouse you will have you'll have six
and seven languages spoken but curiously
you never hear a child practicing a
distinct tongue they simply wait watch
listen and begin to speak and we went
back to make a film with the people of
the Anaconda last year and where all of
this comes together is in ritual where
you don't have isolated individuals and
by being ayahuasca in the forest you
have 250 men in full ritual regalia five
days and nights imbibing copious amounts
of ayahuasca literally becoming the
ancestors to journey through sacred
space back to the points of origin that
don't exist in historical time but
exists today in which mythology itself
becomes an incredibly sophisticated land
management plan which literally allowed
populations numbering in the tens of
thousands indeed in the millions to live
in the Amazon we realize now that to
have tried to understand the Amazon as
we did would be like trying to
understand British civilization from the
perspective of the Hebrides after London
had been nucleated
by an atomic bomb what we're now
discovering is that the Amazon is a
place of huge civilizations and indeed
the incredible thing is the people the
Anaconda are still too there to inform
us precisely how those civilizations
found a way to live in that forest and
that was to me the most remarkable
expedition I've done in the last 20
years but this idea of turning to
landscape as a key to character and a
key to understanding culture I think is
something that came to me very early in
my career I was very fortunate to be
part of a remarkable study of a plant
known to the Inca as a divine leaf of
immortality coca the notorious source of
cocaine and we knew at the time of that
assignment which was I must say the
dream academic grant of the 1970s a
quarter million dollars from the US
government a brand-new Dodge pickup
truck a wonderful dog named Pogo and
every conceivable drug known to man I
think Tim Plowman and I ate our way
through South America but coca became
this remarkable lens for understanding
and the in life you know in the time of
the Inca shrine could not be approached
if you did not have coke in your mouth
unable to cultivate coca at the
elevation of the imperial capital of
cusco the Inca replicated it in gold and
silver leaf in fields that colored the
landscape and to this day there is no
gesture that occurs in the Andes that is
not mediated by some kind of reciprocal
exchange of the energy of that sacred
leaf with the landscape itself no field
can be planted or harvested no child led
into the realm of of life or elder taken
into the realm of death without some
kind of ritual gesture involving the
sacred plant and the lens of coca then
opened up these remarkable sense of
relationships which I define in the book
the wayfinders as a note as a notions of
sacred geography
and again I'm not speaking in terms of
hippie ethnography what I'm saying is
what does it really mean to believe as
the people in the Andes do that the
earth is alive dependent on the human
imagination responsive to the needs of
human beings even as human beings are in
turn responsible for certain mutual
obligations toward the earth itself the
point isn't whether a mountain is in
fact a mountain deity a sacred being or
whether it's a pile of rock the
interesting observation is how the
perspective changes the relationship
between the human society and that
natural resource I mean I I was raised
in the forests of British Columbia to
believe that those forests existed to be
cut that was a foundation of the
ideology of scientific forestry that I
learned in school and I practiced as a
logger in the woods that made me a
profoundly different human being than my
friends amongst the first nations who
believed that those same forests were
the abode of who kook and the crooked
beak of heaven and the cannibal spirits
had well to the north end of the world
spirits that would have to be embraced
during the Hammad's initiation such that
the wisdom of the wild could be brought
back to the community during the
potlatch now again the issue isn't
whether that forest was mere cellulose
and board feed or whether it was a
domain of the spirits the interesting
observation is how those beliefs result
in different outcomes
you know the First Nations of British
Columbia have lived on that coast for
thousands of years having had a relative
or the modest ecological footprint
whereas the worldview from which I
emerged has ravaged that coast in less
than three generations and so I've
always been interested in these ritual
gestures that create the sense of
relationship and of course in the Andes
it's not a metaphysical thing but it's
something people live every day people
see that the clouds condense into the
rain on the flanks of the mountains they
see the rain brings fertility to the
fields they live in a in a place where a
hailstorm or a deep frost can wipe out a
crop in 15 minutes
as occurred in Cusco in 1983 so this
idea of having to proof
the natural world comes in a sense
naturally and no no on it happens both
in the community level and a kind of pan
Andean level now I've spent a lot of
time around a small town called Shan
shadow outside of Cusco side of the
Summer Palace of tapa Inca you ponky the
second of the great Inca rulers and once
each year this remarkable event occurs
whereby the fastest young boy from every
Hamlet is given the honor for the day of
becoming a woman and dressed up in the
traje of his sister or his mother he
becomes a transvestite known as the
while a cop and as the while akka he
must carry the ritual banners of the
community on a run but it's not your
ordinary run it starts off at 11,500
feet runs down 2,000 feet to the base of
the sacred mountain the Abu and to
Kitaoka and then soars up to 15,000 feet
only to fall away the other side to the
sacred Valley only to climb once more
over to Soaring and the in passes over
the course of a very long day the entire
perimeter of the race is the boundary of
the community a boundary that is marked
by millones or ethos the the sacred
piles of dirt were the while akka must
spin to bring the vortex of the feminine
to the mountaintop where coca is given
to the earth where libations of alcohol
are blown to the wind and the metaphor
is so beautiful is that the people go
into the mountains as individuals but
through sacrifice which means to make
sacred and through exhaustion they
emerge as a community that through
ritual gesture has once again reaffirmed
its sense of belonging and more
importantly its sense of obligation to
that particular spirit of place and I
can assure you that when I completed the
momento at the age of 48 I was the first
outsider Steve King ran part of it my
old friend here I think I was the first
person to complete it and Steve would
have completed it with me if he had been
in the field I'm sure but I also
can promise you that I only managed to
complete it by chewing more coca leaves
in one day than anyone in the 2,000 year
history of the plan but these localized
pilgrimages become pan Andean in these
fantastic rituals like the quiet et
which occurs close to Corpus Christi
when the Pleiades reemerge in the sky
and it's kind of like an Andean
Woodstock it has deep pre-columbian
roots tens of thousands of Indian people
from all over the southern Andes emerge
on this sacred valley of the sinakara
which is dominated by the three tongues
of the coca panca glacier and in this
perfect fusion of pre-columbian and
Catholic beliefs which is the reality of
the pan Andean world of the last 500
years the ritual symbolism is profound
people move up into the high mountains
carrying a black stone to be placed at
the foot of the glaciers they move up
following the stages of the cross in
pure Christian liturgical procession but
they do so in the shadow of ascend Gatti
the most sacred of all the summits of
the Andean Empire and then they carry
their crosses from their communities
into the ice to plant them into the ice
overnight that they may become empowered
by the resonance of Pachamama the people
who carry the crosses up the Pablito are
those uniquely empowered to deal with
the Conda novels the spirits of the Dead
that dwell on the place of of ambiguity
which is ice now these sorts of
contemporary rituals even allow us to
deconstruct such common or such iconic
places of Machu Picchu how many of you
have been to Machu Picchu lots of you
I'm sure many of you heard it described
as a lost city it was only a lost city
in the fantasies of the National
Geographic it's perfectly situated
geographically to control access to an
to sue you the one quadrant of teh want
to sue you think an empire the Incan
never could totally dominate the eastern
lowland a vital source of coca
medicinal inspiration medicinal plants
it also controlled the access
geographically to the sacred valley
leading up to cuzco you simply have to
look around and you can see the network
of roads that linked it in to the 14,000
kilometers of roads that the Inca built
in the less than 100 years of the
Empire's existence but more
significantly Machu Picchu is linked in
to Andean notions of cosmology and
sacred geography if you go to the center
point as you all did the Inca Wattana
what Bingham calls the hitching post of
the Sun this strange abstract monolith
carved out of stone at the center you
suddenly notice that the Abu the sacred
mountain of Machu Picchu which is a
Sugarloaf Mountain many of you climbed
one a Picchu the light that falls in the
face of the inti Wattana
constantly reflects the light that is on
the face of the Abu if you come to the
south of the into Wattana you discover
an altar go to the top of the summit of
one a Picchu you find the parallel altar
do a direct north-south bearing and you
find your astonishment that that bearing
bisects ent Wattana continues to this to
the horizon where bisects all can tie
the second of the most sacred mountains
of the Inca the mountain that
metaphysically is seen as a source of
all the water for the site of Machu
Picchu but then it gets even more
complex because the milky way which is
the most important astronomical
configuration for the Inca when the
southern cross is at the southernmost
point in the sky it too is in that same
direct bearing and if you climb Machu
Picchu mountain you find that the villa
Nothe or the Urubamba which like a
serpent envelops Machu Picchu and the
vilcanota or the Otto bomba was of
course seen as the earthly equivalent of
the Milky Way it was also the trajectory
along which vehicle walked at the dawn
of time when he brought the Empire into
existence but where is the Urubamba born
in the snow fields of hacen gotti
so 500 years after the conquest when
people go back to the glaciers of the
they are echoing notions of sacred
geography that we know go back for 1500
2000 years in the Andes and if what you
experience in the southern part of Peru
is a perfect reflection of the syncretic
reality that came with the conquest by
the Spanish there was one place in South
America where the pre-columbian voices
remained unfettered and that's in the
Sierra Nevada de Santa Marta of Colombia
the law this incredible isolated
volcanic Massif that soars to 6,000
meters right out of the coastal plain of
Colombia the largest coastal mountain
range on earth a mountain range was the
homeland of the elder brothers the four
tribes the conch Juana the wee WA the
Kogi and the otter Wakko's who were
descendants of the tyrona civilization
which was the civilization that carpeted
the Caribbean coastal plain and the
civilization that was vanquished by the
Spanish in 1571 in the wake of that
their descendants slipped up into this
mountain and transformed their
civilization from that of a warrior
based a militaristic society into truly
a devotional society of peace they call
themselves the elder brothers the
central metaphor of their culture is the
loom they say upon this loom I weave my
life as they move up and down the slopes
of the Sierra Nevada exploiting various
ecological niches they refer to their
movements as threads so that over the
course of a lifetime
you literally weave a cloth over the
body of the earth itself so Dunkwa and
indeed when they plant a garden the
women plant the southern half like this
the men plant the northern half like
this so that you turn the garden on top
of itself you literally get a piece of
cloth they believe that their prayers
and their prayers alone maintain the
cosmic balance and the training for the
priesthood and they still remain to this
day in a blood-stained continent ruled
by a ritual priesthood is intense
in the extreme the young acolytes are
taken away from their families at the
age of three and four with the support
of the parents and then sequestered for
18 years to nine year periods
deliberately chosen to mimic the nine
months of gestation in their natural
mother's womb now they are
metaphorically in the womb of the great
mother and for that entire time the
world only exists as an abstraction as
they are taught the values of their
society which maintain that their
prayers and ritual gestures literally
maintained the cosmic balance and after
this incredibly intense initiation which
Reichel dolma Tov the legendary
Colombian anthropologist reported in the
1940s literally occurred in the darkness
of the men's temple they are let out
before light and taken on pilgrimage and
for the first time in their lives they
literally see the world in all of its
beauty and they are told you see as I've
told you it's yours to protect
Michael never accompanied one of those
pilgrimages and it was something I
always wanted to do I wanted to find out
if it could possibly be
as exotic and intense as he had
described and my opportunity came just
about two years ago when this man came
into my office of the National
Geographic a leader of a delegation of
Mamos who were there in Washington at
the invitation of the Colombian embassy
and as donítö via Fania began to speak
to me I interrupted him I said you know
I hate to be bothersome but you you look
an awful lot like an old friend of mine
and the man on the right here turned out
to be Danny Lowe's father who I lived
with with Tim Plowman in 1974 and I said
Danny lo I hate to be rude but you may
not think you know me but when you were
a baby I carried you on my back up and
down the mountain and then I showed him
a photograph of his father from a book
of mine one river
we had a great laugh and out of that
kind of camaraderie came this really
remarkable invitation to accompany you
Henny oh the boy on the left his now UPS
is now this man he
second from the left and Alberto was
murdered by the paramilitary so there
was this very big emotional kind of
reconnection that led to this remarkable
journey where we began at the sea and
accompanied one of these initiative the
ice and the metaphor is you take
products from the sea to the sacred ice
and products from the ice back to the
sea and we discovered that the
apprenticeship is indeed as intense as
rykel described it's not always in the
darkness of the hut but the young
apprentice to be never leaves the
confines of the men's ceremonial center
until the moment of the journey and the
journey takes you literally above the
trees to what the people call the heart
of the world every single ripple in the
landscape resonates with mythological
significance even the hats of the otter
Wakko's wear are an echo of the sacred
snow found at the heart of the world and
this was an extraordinary journey
because of course those mountains have
been a center of insurgency and the FARC
and the ELN they were there and we had
the misfortune of being stalked by a
FARC patrol and so in the end we had to
actually abandon our quest just before
the sacred lakes and slip away led by
two of the otter Wakko's but we were
fortunate in having trained we walked
cameraman so he simply gave the camera
to our colleagues and they finished the
film for us as we had a kind of
wild-west escape that took us back down
to the sea but the extraordinary thing
is to think that two hours from Miami
Beach in a homeland that is still on the
coast
you know cluttered with brothels and
discotheques and high-rises you still
have the elder brothers praying every
day for our collective well-being they
they call themselves the elder brothers
and they dismissed the rest of us who
who have in their minds ruined the world
as the younger brothers and they speak
in full and specific paragraphs about
the obligation of human beings
to be stewards of the planet now I was
very very fortunate I think to study not
only with someone like Tim Plowman but
also with the great Richard Evans
Salty's and after several years of
working in South America as an ethno
botanist I kind of lived by Marshall
McLuhan's adage that if it works it's
obsolete and there got to a point where
I just felt I had done most of what I
wanted to do in the botanical realm and
I was looking for another kind of
challenge and I was at the right
institution because there was always
some possibility lurking in the fourth
floor area of Richard Evans Salty's and
one winter day in the in February of
1982 he summoned me to his office and
asked me very casually whether I was
interested in going down to Haiti
infiltrating the secret societies and
securing the formula of a drug used to
make zombies well naturally I said yes
and I went off to this remarkable
Haitian African reality thinking that it
might be a lark having no idea that it
would end up consumed in four years of
my life because what I experienced in
Haiti within 24 hours was something that
had eluded me in the Amazon for all
those years and that was truly a window
wide open to the mystic and I added
these images tonight because Haiti
should be in all of our thoughts tonight
literally it may be the case of hundreds
of thousands of people have died in this
terrible earthquake the epicenter of
which was ten kilometers from the voodoo
temple where I did my research but I
went down there as naive as anyone about
this remarkable religion and it's
interesting if I asked you to name the
great religions of the world what would
you say to Christianity Islam Buddhism
Judaism whatever there's always one
continent left out sub-saharan Africa
the tacit assumption being that black
people had no religion well of course
they did and voodoo is not a black magic
cult is simply the distillation of very
profound religious ideas that came over
during the tragic era
slavery and became sown in the fertile
soil of the new world the essence of
Voodoo is a dynamic relationship between
the living and the dead whereby the
living give birth to the dead the dead
became become seen as a multiple
expressions of the divine but in this
quintessentially democratic faith even
the dead must be made to serve the
living to serve the living they must
become manifest to become manifest they
must be recalled to the world to
momentarily displace the souls of the
living so that for that brief shining
moment human being and God become one in
the same that's why the Haitian people
always said to me you white people go to
church and speak about God we dance in
the temple and become God and spirit
possession is not some kind of psychic
unrest it's a moment of divine grace
where the human being literally is taken
by the Spirit and as a spirit you cannot
be harmed and so you see these powerful
gestures an individual here in Benin and
slicing into his skin with a with a
razor to show the power of his faith or
more profoundly in Haiti voodoo acolytes
handling burning embers with impunity
and this this ability to to cast the
body into trance was one that absolutely
enchanted me and I think more than
anything gave me a sense of the power of
belief the power of culture to create
new realities so this is literally a
photograph taken if you went ten
kilometers from that aesthetic Boulevard
you would hit the epicenter of where
this earthquake happened yesterday so
you know in the end we sort of have to
ask yourself what kind of world do we
want to live in we have this sort of
sense that you know these culture is
quaint and colorful though they may be
or somehow destined to fade away as if
by natural laws if their failed attempts
of being us failed attempts at being
modern nothing could be further from the
truth change is no threat to culture all
cultures are always dancing with new
possibilities for life technology is no
threat to culture
technology is a gift to culture
these aren't cultures destined to fade
away in every case these are dynamic
living people's being driven out of
existence by identifiable forces and
that's actually an optimistic
observation because it suggests that if
human beings are the agents of cultural
destruction we can be the facilitators
of cultural survival now when I did the
research on zombies I wrote a book that
was made into the worst Hollywood movie
in history called the Serpent and the
rainbow and Hemingway said that if you
sell a book to Hollywood you should
start off in Arizona drive to the
California line throw the book over and
go back to Tucson and have a drink
I didn't do that I with my good friend
Ian McKenzie a linguist here in the
audience went off to the rainforests of
Borneo because we had heard about the
plight of the punana and I think we were
both enchanted with the idea of a
nomadic people living in the rainforest
because of course nomadic life is what
we all as humans once shared until the
Neolithic Revolution of 12,000 years ago
and nomadic cultures are profoundly
different how do you measure wealth for
example in a society in which there is
no incentive to accumulate material
possessions where wealth becomes seen as
a strength of social relations between
people because if those relations fray
everybody suffers by the same token a
certain form of generosity becomes
reflexive because you never know when
you will be the next to bring food to
the table or who will be the next to
bring food to the table I once gave a
cigarette to a pen and woman and watched
as she tore it apart just to distribute
the individual strands of tobacco
equitably rendering the product useless
but honoring the obligation to share and
the plan had a quality of being that has
struck every outside observer who's been
fortunate enough to live amongst them
and of course that way of life in a
generation was swept away at a time when
you heard so much of the d4 about the
deforestation of the Amazon in the mid
80s Brazil perhaps produced 3% of the
tropical log exports
as much as 45% was coming from Malaysia
much of it from the homeland of the
Penang and so in a single generation a
way of life
morally inspired inherently right was
literally collapsed along with the
rainforests that in the sense had given
at birth and I'll never forget the the
day when Ian called me from I think he
was in Singapore and I was in Lhasa to
let me know that the last of the nomadic
Penang had in fact settled and nomadic
societies are not manok it's almost
there's a whole other thing that goes on
which is that in a non written tradition
it seems that there's a relationship to
the natural world that I've I've
experienced with with with non literate
societies it's almost as if in the same
way that we can hear the voices of a of
a character and we read a novel my
experience with Athabascan people's in
northern Canada or the Penan it's almost
like the flight of a bird becomes a
cursive script of nature like a
vocabulary written on the wind and the
thought that a way of life could have
slipped away within a lifetime is is
almost too haunting to to imagine but
these sorts of industrial intrusions do
not just occur in distant realms of the
world as my closest friend in Canada
Austrian as' who is leading the fight
for a place that we call the sacred
headwaters by an extraordinary accident
of geography three of our most important
salmon rivers ask ena the Stikine and
the NASS are all born in the same
meadows at a place known to the
indigenous people as a sacred headwaters
that's a place that there are now
proposals for the extraction of
anthracite coal copper and gold mines
and most threatening of all a proposal
by Royal Dutch Shell to impose coal bed
methane extraction template of wells
that will literally blanket the entire
headwaters and what I find curious about
these developments environmental
concerns aside is what they tell us
about the way we approach the natural
world
we take it as an to be quite normal that
a handful of men back in Toronto can
cobble together a company with less
history than my dog get on line and
secure the subsurface rights to a place
that they have never been of which they
have no experience the narratives of
which they have no connection to and
secure simply by promising the
government a certain revenue flow either
in terms of Taxation
or royalties they secure the right to by
definition in their own self-interest
leave that landscape transformed and
indeed violated forever we take that as
a given but it's highly anomalous in
human affairs the only place in the
world I know where such a miracle of
geography happens is on the slopes of
Mount Kailash in Tibet where the Indus
the Brahmaputra and the Ganges are born
the I you can't even set foot on that
mountain let alone impose industrial
infrastructure and the thought of doing
so would condemn your lineage for all
time we take this as an absolute normal
way of industrializing the wild there's
not a single metric in the calculus that
rationalizes the industrialization of
the wild that takes into account the
value of the land left alone or the cost
inherent in its destruction for the
commons which is the rest of us we think
of that as normal but it's highly
anomalous in human affairs and it's
certainly not the way that the Talton
people think and it's not the way that
the Aboriginal people of Australia think
I recently made a film for the National
Geographic on The Dreamtime
because I wanted to go to what had
historically been seen as the
civilization or the culture that more
than any was seen to be different than
that of the West and indeed when the
British first washed ashore on the
shores of Australia they found a strange
landscape strange animals and strange
people who looked strange who clearly
had a simple primitive technology and
what most offended the British is that
the Aboriginal people of Australia
clearly had never attempted to improve
upon their lot that was a
offensive to the British because
self-improvement was the ethos of the
Victorian age the British concluded of
course of the Aboriginal people of
Australia were savages and they simply
began to shoot them as recently as 1902
it was debated in the parliament in
Australia as to whether Aboriginal
people were human beings as recently as
the 1960s a textbook for kids in
Australia a Treasury of fauna of
Australia included the Aborigines as
amongst the interesting examples of
Australian wildlife but what was it that
was really going on what the British
failed to understand was the Aboriginal
people had in fact developed one of the
most extraordinary philosophical
traditions in the history of humanity we
know from studies of the y-chromosome
that the Aboriginal people of Australia
were the first wave of human beings to
walk out of Africa they reached
Australia remarkably quickly and
certainly had settled a continent by
50,000 years ago they reached that most
parsimonious of continents and then they
went walking over time establishing as
many as 10,000 clan territories all of
which were linked together by a single
idea and that idea was the Dreaming and
the Dreaming wasn't a dream it was a
stray it was a state of perpetual
existence in multi-dimensional space the
purpose of life for the Australian was
not to improve on anything but simply to
do the ritual gestures that were
necessary to maintain the world exactly
as it was at the time of the first
dawning when the Rainbow Serpent spread
its body across the earth and the
ancestors sang the world into being in
not one of the 670 dialects and
languages of Australia is there a word
for time past present or future the
Aboriginal people of Australia were not
victims of history there were people who
in a sense had defeated the notion of
history itself a people who traditions
answered both the question how and why
and the fascinating thing is not to say
who was right and who was wrong or to
idealize in any particular way the
adaptation of these people but to
we ask the obvious question had human
beings followed this particular
devotional philosophy yes we would not
have put a man on the moon but we also
wouldn't be talking about the capacity
of human beings through climate change
to transform the biological life
supports of the planet now very often
the threat to culture is ideological
this is a photograph I took of a
Buddhist nun at Angkor Wat who has had
her but hands and lay feet cut from her
body for the crime of practicing her
religious faith and if we slip for a
moment into the mountains of Tibet we
see the consequences of that fateful
moment when Mao Zedong the Marxist
communist ideologue who had the
remarkable achievement of being
responsible for the death of more of his
own people in his lifetime than Hitler
and Stalin combined well Mao Zedong
famously whispered into the ears of his
Holiness the Dalai Lama that all
religion was poisoned his holiness knew
what was coming and of course with the
invasion of Tibet and the final
transformation of Tibet in 1959 1.2
million Tibetans may have died and 6,000
temples were reduced to riprap and dust
and you have to ask as I asked matthieu
ricard what was it that so threatened
the marxist materialists in this curious
and remarkable faith of Buddhism what is
the Buddhist Dharma it comes down to the
Four Noble Truths all life is suffering
by that the Buddha didn't mean that all
life is negation he just meant that [ __ ]
happens the cause of suffering is
ignorance and by that the Buddha did not
mean stupidity he meant a tendency of
human beings in their cruel delusions to
cling to the illusion of their own
centrality in the stream of divine
desire the third of the Noble Truths was
a delineate was the revelation that
ignorance could be overcome and the
fourth and the most practical was the
literal delineation of a contemplative
practice that if followed not only had a
possibility of a transformation of the
human heart but had 2500 years of
empirical evidence and such a
transformation
happen and with mature and with share
Abama to Tibetan doctor I undertook a
couple of years ago this kind of
pilgrimage of the heart to the flanks of
Everest under the graces of truce a grim
push a the head of the nygma tradition
not to climb the mountain but to go to a
place where we could encounter a true
Bodhisattva a true hero a wisdom hero a
woman who had given up the possibility
of her own liberation from the realm of
samsara and stayed in the realm of
samsara to facilitate the liberation of
other sentient beings we went up past
the caves where sherab had spent a year
of his seven years of medical training
in solitary isolation and we came
eventually through the graces of macho
and twisted grim Pichet to this site a
woman who forty-five years before had
gone into isolated retreat and for all
of that time she had lived in a cell at
a nunnery chanting a single mantra and
the minute this door opened the first
time light had fallen on her face from
the Sun in 45 years I half expected to
meet a mad woman instead I met a woman
whose eyes sparkled with happiness and
contentment and this is the point for
the Buddhists the proof of the efficacy
of the science of the mind is the
serenity achieved by the practitioner of
the Four Noble Truths so in the end my
point is we have a choice what kind of
world we want to live in Margaret Mead
said before she died that her greatest
fear that was it as we drifted toward
this bland the amorphous worldview not
only would the entire range of the human
spirit be reduced to a more narrow
modality of thought but we would wake
from a dream having forgotten that there
were even other possibilities of life
itself the other people's the world
aren't failed attempts of being us their
unique answers to a fundamental question
what does it mean to be human and the
reason this is so important is that
culture is not trivial culture is not
decorative it's not the songs we sing
it's not the robes we wear
fundamentally culture is about a body of
ethical and moral values that every
culture places around the individual to
keep at bay the barbaric heart that
history so sadly teaches us lies beneath
the surface of every human being it's
culture that allows us to make sense out
of sensation to find order and meaning
in the universe it's culture that allows
us as Lincoln said to always seek the
better angels of our nature and if you
want to know what happens when culture
is lost when through volition or
coercion the individual turns their back
on the constraints of tradition often to
be cast into the world of disaffection
and alienation perhaps in pursuit of a
world of affluence that the individual
may aspire to but rarely achieve and
instead finds him or sell him or herself
simply on the lowest rung of economic
ladder that goes nowhere you simply have
to look around the world to the points
of chaos the butt-naked brigades in
Liberia the eastern Congo or rape is a
systematic weapon of war the insanity of
The Shining Path of the gates of Lima or
the Maus in Katmandu culture is not
trivial culture is the glue of
civilization it is culture that allows
us to be human and the world is finally
waking up to this extraordinary gift of
the human imagination has brought into
being by culture when I was a kid the
Inuit people the Arctic were dismissed
as savages and indeed when the British
first went to the Arctic they took the
Inuit to be savages the inuit took the
british to be gods what the British
failed to understand is that there was
no better sign of human genius than the
ability to survive in a harsh
environment on a technology that was
limited to what you could make from the
cold
the Inuit didn't fear the cold they took
advantage of it the runners of their
sleds were originally made of fish three
arctic char wrapped in frozen and
wrapped in a caribou hide skin and then
grease for the stomach content of the
caribou the Inuit didn't fear the cold
they took advantage of it this
photograph I took 250 kilometres out on
the sea ice north of the glue lock in
the Canadian Arctic that night the
temperature dropped windchill to minus
80 Celsius these guys made an igloo
survived in a way that I could never
have imagined a people for whom blood on
ice is not a sign of death but an
affirmation of life itself and I've
often told the story that I've always
thought was a prophet call when I was
narwhal hunting with these Inuit from
northern Baffin Island they told me a
story of the dark days of Canadian
history when we forced the Inuit into
settlements in the 1950s to establish
our sovereignty in the Arctic and this
Manoel iyx grandfather refused to go
into the settlement and so fearful for
his life the people took away all of his
weapons and all of his tools and and so
what did the old man do he slipped
outside into the Arctic night pulled
down his caribou hide and seals
controllers defecated into his hand and
as a thesis began to freeze he shaped it
in the form of a blade as he implemented
form he put a spray of saliva and along
the leading edge and when the [ __ ] knife
as it's known was finally created from
the cold he used it to kill a dog he
skinned the dog improvised a harness
with the skin of the dead dog improvised
a ribbed sled from the ribcage of the
dead dog harnessed up an adjacent living
dog and [ __ ] knife and belt disappeared
in the Arctic night now when I you talk
about getting by with nothing but I
thought that was a prophet all until I
read in the journals of Peter Freudian
who was with Rasmussen on the fifth tule
expedition and Freud khun's out there in
a blizzard and to protect himself he
puts off digs a trough and the snow
pulls his sled on top and then becomes
encased in ice in a coffin of his own
making and a very offhanded way in his
primary journal says I thought of making
a [ __ ] knife but I couldn't really
maneuver so but the tragedy in all of
this finally tonight is is that having
endured so much and the in a way the
Inuit are symbol of cultural survival
and adaptation now they're confronting
something that's beyond their capacity
to control this is a photograph taken in
Kanak the northernmost community in the
world in Northwest Greenland in the
language of the polar eskimo the word
Selah means both weather
and consciousness and we flew from
Igloolik with a nuke friend of ours who
had made the journey with his dogs to
Northwest Greenland and as we crossed
miss sound it was March month 12 degrees
south of North Pole we noticed that Theo
was looking out the window and he had
begun to cry and we couldn't figure out
what his what was wrong and of course
the answer was he was looking down at
open water where there should have been
ice and when we went hunting in northern
Greenland we had to use boats and the
season of the ice which used to come in
in September and remain until July now
comes in in November and is gone by
March so the way of life in a sense has
been cut in half and I think in a way if
you if you look at the subtitle of this
book why ancient wisdom matters in the
modern world you really only have to say
two words climate change not because we
are somehow going to go back to a
pre-industrial past or that any culture
should be kept from the brilliance of
modernity but the very existence of
different cultures and different ways of
thinking puts the lie to those who say
that we're on a train wreck to history
it shows the folly of those who say that
we cannot change as we know we must
change the fundamental way we inhabit
the planet because in the end I think we
need these multiple visions of these
multiple cultures because they're not
only our collective heritage they become
part of our kind of naked geography of
hope thank you very much
way to go is a table where I can put all
the many questions that nobody was able
to write because they were so busy
listening to you I've never had so few
questions but they're obviously out
there so keep them coming up to you
Alexander he will rush up from time to
time with questions and so we will
proceed I'm trying to figure out if it's
an artifact that you had to go to
absolutely fierce places to find these
intact sophisticated very complicated
cultures and what I'm wondering is are
the cultures that profound and amazing
because they're in a very tough place
you talked about the ethanol geography
or the the only places are surviving
because those of us were looking for
real estate haven't figured out a way to
do that there well you know none of
these societies you know it's so I think
none of these societies are isolated you
know in a presentation like this you
could give the impression of that I mean
the exciting thing is that that they're
not isolated they're completely
connected through the internet through
communication and yet still they've made
the choice and and it's very important
because we're not talking about freezing
people in time you can't make a
rainforest Park of the mind it's it's
not about the modern versus a
traditional it's about the rights of
free people to choose the components of
their lives and for example one of the
most interesting things about the polar
eskimo and the word Eskimo is a
pejorative term in the Arctic but not in
in in in in in Greenland is that if you
go to the village of Connick you find
these wonderful little Danish houses
everybody's got DVDs everybody's got
cell phones but they also their dogs and
unlike in the Arctic where the dogs have
been basically swept away by his
technology and ski-doos and snowmobiles
the people of Greenland recognize that
dogs were the cultural pivot and if you
kept the dogs you kept everything that
because the very act of keeping dogs of
hunting with dogs gave you a certain
freedom on the ice it gave you a sense
of independence from the cash economy
it demanded skills that created a
lineage with your past so it's very
important that no anthropologists
talking about freezing people in time
you know it's about it's about asking
what kind of world we all want to live
in now there's a question related that
from Melinda often do you see the impact
of Google Earth affecting these remote
safe-haven cultures that you're talking
about around the world you know again
you get back this idea that the the the
supposition there is that these are
fragile people you know which is a kind
of a paternalistic way of thinking about
it I mean these are some of the toughest
most dedicated and and and and and you
know if I say that you know technology
and change doesn't threaten culture
power threatens culture the the the
other side of the story is that the
power and resilience of culture is
incredible you know when I first went
for example to the Auto Wakko's in 1974
boards what people in in in in Bogota
would say to me por que que de vida por
que quiero vivir aircon anti socio why
do you want to live with the dirty
people the last five Colombian
presidents as a first act of office have
gone to the mammals to pay homage to the
tradition when I I didn't finish the
story of the Northwest Amazon the reason
250 men in ritual regalia are taking
ayahuasca and becoming the ancestors is
because of a political decision made in
Colombia when I we went back on this
expedition with Martin von Hildebrand
and Steven Hugh Jones who's a former
head of anthropology at Cambridge who
has worked with a balasana since 1968 he
had been part of a BBC series called
disappearing worlds when he saw what was
going on in the longhouse at Porto
Alegre he got on the satellite phone to
his wife was also an anthropologist he
said Christine you won't believe your
[ __ ] eyes it's like the only people
that disappeared are the [ __ ]
missionaries and and and in fact I'm
just I'm quoting him erudite scholar
from Cambridge but what indeed happened
is that the father of the current
Colombian ambassador Karolina Barco for
Helio Barco loved Indians and
came to office in 1985 he made this
young anthropologist Martine von
Hildebrand his head of Indian Affairs
and he's just said Martine do something
for the Indians and in five
extraordinary years Martine did more
than something he secured legal land
title for an area of land the size of
the United Kingdom encoded in the 1991
constitution of Columbia and behind the
veil of that security and the violence
created by the current situation in
Colombia which kept the federal state
out of the Amazon this entire new dream
of the earth was reborn so this idea
that you know we're talking about the
past we're not talking about the past
we're talking about where we're moving
forward and it's you know the answer is
politics
you know Canada created a territory
called Nunavut you know we gave back
total administrative control of an area
of land half the size of Western Europe
to 26,000 Inuit people when I was a
logger on the Queen Charlotte Islands
the Haida used to say who the hell was
Queen Charlotte
now even our conservative Prime Minister
two weeks ago legally changed the name
of that archipelago forevermore it will
be known as Haida Gwaii in legal
Canadian law you know so I'm very
optimistic about where this can all go
when you were logging in the Queen
Charlotte's were there Indians on your
crew Indians never got above the landing
in other words if you were native you
could be a rigging slinger you could be
a choker man you could never be a faller
yeah I was a choker setter didn't arise
up to that follower thing did you go up
the trees did you we that we had Mozilla
artists by then this decline er not
decline thing it you know Edward or
Wilson you spoke of has talked about
this kind of period of a bottleneck that
the whole world seems to be in climate
change is part of it loss of
biodiversity is part of the loss of
cultural diversity as part of it in a
sense is that that getting through it
there's fraud sin some let up once on
the other side you know if we make it
there for the the cultures the species
that make it through this weird period
of 50 or 100 years are going to be in
better shape do you sense that with the
cultures that
talking about totally you know I always
say pessimism is an indulgence I mean if
you're a father you you can't be
pessimistic and and if you look we're so
impatient with history but you know it
within our lifetimes I always say you
know women have gone from the kitchen to
the boardroom gay people from the closet
to the altar african-americans from the
woodshed to the White House 30 years ago
just getting people stopped throwing
garbage out of a car window was a great
environmental victory no one spoke the
biosphere now it's part of the
vernacular of schoolchildren you know
and I think that that what's going to
drive this transformation will not be
the nation state I mean I have a very
strong sense I'm the nation state as
Daniel Bell said has become too big for
the little problems of the world too
little for the big problems of the world
and and there were 60 nation states in
the year 1900 and that there's now 190
most of them dysfunctional and I really
saw that at Copenhagen during the during
the earth summit of the climate summit I
mean the the posturing by the nation
states all of them was really appalling
so they Werner Copenhagen they're an
anthropologist at Copenhagen the climate
conference that's interesting what do
you see is an anthropologist well they
send me over there not as an expert on
climate change I just sort of to try to
someone actually the full stories that
Nissan is about to launch an
all-electric car called the leaf and
they one of their executives had read
this book new book of mine and they
thought maybe this would be interesting
just take a kind of anthropological look
at this moment in time and what I found
sort of interesting was that the the the
posturing by the nation-states I mean
you had you had you know the developed
world totally exaggerating their plans
for carbon reduction the third world
so-called clamoring for cash
in an appalling way Saudi Arabia asking
for compensation African African nations
using terms like reparations as if there
had been a carbon conspiracy of foot
since the birth of the Industrial
Revolution the European Union
sanctimoniously talking about is 20%
carbon reduction quota from 1990 when
they knew full and well they'd already
achieve 12% of that just by admitting
the 13 failed states of the former
Soviet bloc China talking about reducing
its carbon intensity as if you know
which all that meant is that you know
carbon emissions could continue to go up
as long as they didn't go up at a higher
rate than the kind of steroidal growth
of the Chinese economy
you had India basically saying well you
know you had it for a hundred years it's
our turn to poison the world I mean it
left you it left you really uninspired
by the nation state by bureaucrats but
on the other hand I found the corporate
presence very interesting a very strong
sense that the Green Revolution which is
you've written but so well in your book
I mean you know if everything you think
bad about you know the most I don't
believe in conspiracies in particular in
America I've never met an American to
keep a secret little amount of
conspiracy but but even in your your
worst fears of capitalist corporate
greed should be make you very happy
about what's gonna happen with climate
change because if they're this kind of
mercenary they're gonna be going after
this big-time question from topic it
looks like first how it ten thousand
years ago the last ice age ended many of
the cultures we saw tonight are older
than that did they have stories of that
time of climate change no I don't know
I'm you know I you know Ian tells a
really incredible see that story of
yours of the Eclipse is really
interesting I can't remember it but
no but I mean I can't give you the
detail I'm not going to steal his
thunder I mean but no but it's a
fantastic story where where where what
what appears in language and intonation
to be a kind of a story sort of like you
know Raven emerging from the clamshell
steel the Sun is in fact a specific
memory of an astronomical event that you
were able to identify as having occur so
what my point is that just because a
language of of memory and and a
narrative may sound imprecise it's manat
clear that it always is imprecise I mean
part of it is you know some of these
events are so people forget that I mean
the people the first nations of Pacific
Northwest for example are relatively
recent arrivals I mean I mean the great
fluorescence of the northwest coast
cooked coast cultures only occurred with
the arrival of the red cedar tree which
is a tree of life and we know
botanically that that only really
reached up the coast to British Columbia
within you know five ten thousand years
ago so some of this mythology is
probably deep memory and some of its
metaphor here's a question from Dana
have you seen the movie Avatar you know
I haven't and I I just got I've gotten
asked by so many news bureaus to talk
about that movie said I haven't seen it
yet no he didn't gauge some interesting
scientists they invented the language
rather carefully they invented the whole
botany they named all the botanical
items out there and so on so you will
enjoy this aspect this question I can't
believe is from somebody named Bo Oz how
do you introduce yourself and integrate
yourself into the societies you visit
such as in Haiti in the Amazon and they
knew it so on then you show up right and
there's a great you know we all do it as
travelers you know I mean this concede
that anthropologists have that you know
there's somehow better travelers and the
normal travel and the travelers are
better than the tourists you know we're
all tourists you know in a way and what
I've found is what I find so interesting
about culture is that for all this sort
of celebration of diversity that I've
spoken about what's fascinating is is a
commonality we share I mean you know
every human population every culture
deals with the same challenges we all
have to have children we often have to
find ways to procreate we have to come
together in a meaningful way that's
consistent we have to deal with the
mystery of death and so what I find
fascinating about culture is that given
that commonality how many different
expressions have emerged over the last
you know forty thousand years so when I
go to another culture I've always found
I'm sure you've found in your own
travels that the same traits that would
make you welcome in somebody's house of
Thanksgiving or the very traits that
would make you welcome in someone's yurt
in Mongolia good manners
self-deprecating sense of humor a
willingness to eat anything that's put
in front of you
to share what no food foods not trivial
I mean I mean I have many times and I
know ian has you'll eat you'll eat food
that you know is going to give you
Giardia or dysentery absolutely not
that's generally in in you know crummy
little border towns not in indigenous
communities but what in my point is that
is is that is is that you can always
treat the Giardia but you can never
rekindle the connection that's broken by
the statement that your superior I
remember when the black canoe bill reads
great monumental sculpture was being
dedicated at the Canadian embassy in
Washington my wife Gayle and I lived in
Vancouver at the time and our house as
Ian will remember was a Waystation for
anybody who wanted to stay there and in
the middle of the night David Phillips
and gujja turned up with this delegation
of Haida that were going to go back to
bless and it was the middle of the night
and they started just pouring into this
house with hampers full of food I mean
venison and dried salmon and herring roe
and everything and finally you know I
just loved watching these tons of food
come into the living room I said good
job you know they do eat in Washington
and he said you think we're gonna let
them feed us you know and that's
foods power how do you finish language I
mean you're going to places where I
apparently you haven't learned the line
I'm terrible this guy I keep pointing to
him but he's one of my best friends we
wrote a book together and he he's a
wonderful linguist what's the book
nomads of the dawn now the thing the
thing is I always exaggerate how many
languages do you really speak
oh he speaks more than a dozen languages
that's true yeah I'm terrible at
languages such as I go with him no I I
speak Spanish and French but I really do
have a poor ear for languages but you
know you know one of the one of the
challenges is that you know I mean
seriously someone like Ian who's doing
longitudinal research with the banan
dedicating himself to learn that
language with all his gifts and he'll be
the first to say that that he would be a
lifetime there and still not be a fluent
speaker of pen and by definition so when
you travel broadly like I do and I think
of myself in a way more of a storyteller
than than an academic in a sense I don't
mean storytelling in that trivial sense
you know I speak French and I speak
Spanish and obviously that gives you a
certain kind of fluidity and in much of
the world equatorial West Africa Latin
America but you know to learn Quechua to
learn Tibetan implies a commitment to
place that I have never made and I
really admire those who do make that
commitment so you typically go in with
somebody with a we're always a team I
mean part of the whole thing is is is is
everything we're doing is the antithesis
of the nineteenth-century concede that
that you can be this sort of you know
white male academic fly-on-the-wall
looking at the book of boo-boos yeah I
mean every one of these film projects we
do for the National Geographic or other
collaborations I mean with with the I
mean the reason the farc knew we're
exactly where we were in Sierra Nevada
is that our journey and itinerary was
absolutely public because we had worked
very closely with going to vend or the
indigenous organization I mean with the
the about asana we never could have made
that film without the cooperation of
fundacion guy Amazonas Martines NGO
and the collaboration of Steven Hugh
Jones so I mean I
I'm never interested in the in the
conceit of like being alone out there
III if you read my books you'll almost
never see the first person personal
pronoun I'm there to tell the story of
the other and if I can be a filter to
facilitate that that's what I but the
more the merrier
there's a big question which my book
whole its discipline got into there's
two whole chapters in urbanization so
urbanization
I could imagine is the death of the
cultures you're talking about or perhaps
by drawing a lot of people but not all
the people off the landscape or some of
these cultures are intact it may in some
ways free them up what's your sense an
organization is huge we're now half
urban we're heading for eighty percent
urban in the world well it's definitely
afraid you know I don't know if you've
all read Stuart's new book but I adore
the book and he converted me to nuclear
that's he did and and and that's new you
we used to get boots I know I know
but but the part of the book that shook
me up the most and disturbed me the most
and I didn't have an answer for and I
couldn't deny was what you talked about
overlay urbanization and that expression
you said the urban era makes one free I
didn't quite buy your idea that the the
favelas are these centers of incredible
rich creativity because they're also
centers of despair but but I sort of
bought what you're saying there I mean I
I think you're absolutely right when you
say the trend the demographic trend to
urbanization is inexorable and may in
fact liberate natural landscapes I
thought that was a great argument do you
see that at all aware you these places
you're going I see I see what I see is
that every it's not an either/or
situation if you go there was no village
in the andes that doesn't have a family
representative in Lima you cannot
survive in the Andes without some access
to the capital metropolitan area same
thing in Kenya and the fascinating thing
in Kenya you know is that you can be
with the Rin Diddley or the Sun Bhutto
and the same guy who buy by day or by
week is your your your policeman on
Saturday is in full regalia doing some
kind of ritual event I don't see it as
an either/or thing I think that
increasingly the same thing with the
Arctic I mean everybody's got a cousin
in Winnipeg you know or someone in
Vancouver and that that's probably that
dialectic economic dialectic is probably
going to be the norm but that doesn't
mean that the Erb urban space has to
consume the rural or grain the rural on
the contrary I mean and there's also a
difference between the kinds of rural
life that you write about which which is
sort of a the the the you know the yoke
of the plough and the hot Sun you know
peasant life you know and and tedium and
boredom but when I when I when and every
culture I've ever seen has trouble
keeping its young there is there's a
magnetic allure to the modern then is is
difficult to account for or resist but
at the same time I see that that that
this this having a foot in the in the
cosmopolitan world does not imply that
you can still and a lot of it is whether
or not the the activities and the
practices of the traditional culture in
place are acknowledged and honored by
the metropolitan society and that's
what's so interesting about Columbia
Columbia in all of its agony has got
this one thing it can be extremely proud
of I mean there's certainly of course
there's certain areas of Columbia where
with the baes and Coca for example
there's been a lot of conflict a lot of
murder a lot of bloodshed but
fundamentally Columbia has in a very
remarkable way
sought a kind of restitution with its
indigenous populations which is
remarkable given the agony that has been
going through I think the question that
everyone has and it's reflected in some
of the questions that we've gotten here
is what is people here people who read
your book people who read see your
videos do or be careful not to do in
terms of honoring and preserving not
helping destroy the culture I think all
you know it's not us versus them all
cultures are famously culturally myopic
I mean the word barbarian comes in the
Greek barbarous if you babbled if you
didn't speak Greek you were a barbarian
right the the Aztec had the same notion
with Nahuatl the the the the name for so
many indigenous peoples translates the
people the implication being that
everybody else is a savage beyond the
pale my argument is that that kind of
cultural myopia is something we can't
afford anymore in an interconnected
world and and so for example if you as a
Marik UNS I think the most powerful
thing you can do is demand of your
government and of your society in
general an openness that we have not had
I mean to me the great exemplar of that
is when the Coalition Provisional
Authority went to Iraq to solve the
problems of a part of the world that was
four thousand years old
sixty-five percent of the coalition the
cadre of the Coalition Provisional
Authority had to get passports for the
first time to go to Iraq so how were
they supposed to solve any problems and
and and and and you know I people often
say you know why does it matter to
someone in San Francisco if a tribe in
Africa disappears well it probably
doesn't but but why does it matter to a
tribe in Africa if San Francisco
disappears it doesn't but wouldn't the
world be a more impoverished place were
either event to happen I mean most of
the world won't see a Monet painting in
a museum or hear a Mozart symphony
performed by an orchestra but does that
imply that the world wouldn't be more
impoverished if those artists hadn't
existed so I think you know they're very
specific
political things that we need to do I
mean and in terms of like we've seen
this in in in our in in and part of it
is just to have a certain basic humility
like I always say you know if a martian
anthropologist came to the united states
they see many wondrous things and if the
measure of success was technological
achievement we would come out shining
but if they looked at the social
structure they'd say some obvious things
like you know half them you know they
say they revere marriage but half their
marriage is in divorce they say they
love their elders but only six percent
of american homes of elders beneath the
same roof as grandchildren they say they
love their kids but they have this weird
slogan 24/7 implying told dedication the
workplace and then they wonder why the
average american youth has spent two
years watching television by the age of
18 their society that is full of its own
hubris but consumes two-thirds of the
world's anti-psychotic drugs while it's
putting 400 million tons of toxic waste
in its environment every year and an
extreme would be one word for
civilization rips down the ancient
forests tears holes in the heavens he
populates the oceans and changes the bio
physics of the atmosphere I mean to me
the this is the the the the the
remarkable thing is that climate change
should finally teach us that were not
the paragon of humanity's potential you
know climate change is humanity's
problem but it wasn't humanity that
created the problem it's useful to
remember that it was a very small subset
of humanity that had a particular
worldview and we think of that world
view as being absolute like you know the
real world like everyone else is you
know sort of failing to keep up with us
or something but it's not these other
people's aren't failed attempts they're
just alternatives you know and and you
would think that the fact that we've
we've brought on this climate crisis
would if anything give us a little bit
of humility about the impact that we've
had on the planet and that's precisely
and that one of these I find so poignant
around the world is that indigenous
people who have played no role in the
creation of climate change are the ones
who are seeing the constant
winces and trying to come to terms with
it for example 80% of the water that
goes to the western shore of South
America comes from Andy and snowmelt
virtually all the agriculture in the
Andes is irrigation based on snowmelt at
the koi a tiki festival the ultimate
gesture is not simply taking the crosses
from the glacier and returning them to
your community traditionally you chip
blocks of ice from that glacier to carry
back to the community both for the
elders who couldn't make the pilgrimage
but also as a perfect gesture to
complete the sacred circle of the divine
scene and witnessing the rate of
recession of those glaciers the people
have taken upon themselves no longer to
chip ice from the glacier that ice of
course is a trivial amount of ice
compared to you know and and and and
that's another thing we forget climate
change isn't just a matter of physics or
economy it's also about psychology
because we have this mechanistic view of
the world which sees a mountain is a
pile of rock but if you really believe a
mountain is a sacred being for whom
you've got obligations ritualistically
and you see that mountain suffering as
the Kogi and the auto Wakko's they see
the ice melting at the heart of the
world they see the the shrinking of
sadhana they see the potter mozi all
fine Meadows drying up they take
personal responsibility for that and
there's nothing they can do about it 500
million people may depend on the Ganges
for water for irrigation and drinking
but for 800 million people the Ganga is
the sacred artery of life how are they
gonna feel when as climatologists
predict within 30 years the Ganges is a
seasonal River
two years ago there was a Hindu ritual
in the highest ritual shrine in Kashmir
where traditionally the lingman the
Lingam of the Felix symbol of Shiva was
formed by the ice and this year it
didn't form and the 2500 pilgrims rioted
well what's going to happen when 800
million people of the subcontinent
realized the gonji no longer flows so I
find it very moving that people for whom
there are no responsibility for the
consummate change you're taking
responsibility in that polar language of
polar eskimo Sela means both weather and
consciousness and and because human
beings breathe in the being the weather
in the weather is a reflection of human
consciousness and they now as when we
went bearded seal hunting walrus hunting
in this rain in March and they just
looked at it and they said this is not
our weather okay look you've clearly got
a theme for the video or a book or maybe
a conference there you know the the
indigenous Copenhagen where you bring
together or go around and get the
stories of exactly the people who are
sort of at the cutting edge or changing
climate whose culture is being impinged
by that and we have a cultural
perspective on it you know what they
have things to say to each other or does
that need to come through a city person
you know they're talking to each other
by the internet I mean the Internet's
becoming a global campfire there are
1500 languages on the Internet
everybody's talking to everybody it's
the most incredible tool of empowerment
shows that we're not losing languages as
fast now thanks to the Internet well I
don't know I I honestly you know I you
know I'm no linguist and I only mention
this this this linguistic data because
one of these are so fascinating is the
the the the the the the academic
consensus is itself haunting I mean if
you Stewart talk to biologists about
species loss there's no consensus what's
fascinating is that there is absolutely
academic consensus amongst linguist
there's fundamental fact I mean no one
knows quite how many languages there are
because of definitions but no one sits
there and says it's not really that bad
and half the languages aren't going and
I find that really haunting and and so I
I mention it's it's it's sort of a
canary in the coal mine and it's a
concrete way that audiences like
yourselves can understand this issue of
culture and one of the fascinating
things about that whole
linguistic story is that one of the
reasons it took so long for the
linguists to sort of start screaming is
because of Noam Chomsky and AH the power
is the power of his idea of deep
structure to languages from what Ian
explained in me is is a it's almost as
if Chomsky viewed that there was certain
find that number of deep languages which
were like the sort of genotype of
language and that what we would call
language was like the phenotypic
expression of that language and so as
long as the deep structures were intact
it didn't really matter if languages
came and went and I'm not sure I'm not
sure that's what he would say but but
then everybody woke up as if the Emperor
had no clothes and it's it's important
that this extinction notion is important
because the analogy is apropos you know
obviously extinction is a natural
phenomenon in nature plants and animals
have always gone extinct but as EO
Wilson says you know the the in general
over the last six hundred million years
speciation the creation of new forms of
life has outpaced extinction and the
world's become a more bio diverse place
by the same token languages have come
and gone we don't speak Latin anymore in
the streets of Rome Syrian or Babylonian
but before Latin faded it had a chance
to leave descendants the Romance
languages of Europe now languages like
species are disappearing at such a rate
that they don't have time to leave
descendents and so this is all part of
this sort of waterfall of destruction
that Wilson talks about well we've
sampled a waterfall of Wade Davis
there's a lot more in his book and Wade
will be out in the lobby signing those
books thank you so much for this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you